welcome back to the David Pakman show
I'm fairing cousin sitting in for David
Pakman today we need to talk about the
tariffs Donald Trump's trade war may not
be garnering the headlines that it was
when it first began but it is still
there things are still getting bad and
in fact they're actually getting worse
but this week we found out from the US
Department of Agriculture that we the US
taxpayers are about to spend six billion
dollars bailing out the farmers who have
been hurt financially from Trump's trade
wars six billion dollars to fix the bad
policies of Donald Trump now there's an
ulterior motive here and I'm gonna get
to that in just a moment but let's talk
about what's actually happening to these
farmers now we have seen reports ever
since probably about a three to four
weeks after the first tariffs hit
soybean farmers were among the first in
this country to really feel the effects
of it not able to sell their goods
overseas because the prices had gone up
too high because of the retaliatory
tariffs of other countries they end up
with these massive surpluses because of
the surpluses they have to lower their
prices here at home they're not making
as much money we have seen major farms
in the United States laying people off
some saying I'm at the point I'm about
to have to shut down we have obviously
seen you know panels on CNN of farmers
saying uh there's Trump trade wars I was
a trump voter but he did this to me I've
been tricked by the devil and others who
say that I was a trump supporter and I
know he's destroying my farm but I'll
vote for him all over again I'm willing
to die for his trade war that's actually
something a trump supporter said in an
interview I'm willing to die for this
trade war that's a level of crazy I
can't even wrap my head around so let's
move on for a second so we know that the
trade war killing farmers here in the
United States figuratively not literally
and they can't sell their goods so
that's why the USDA has come in and said
all right we're gonna give you this
bailout because Donald Trump said we're
we're gonna spend six billion dollars of
taxpayers money that would be better
spent literally on almost anything else
but we're gonna give it to you and the
farmers have all kind of had the same
response we don't want your handouts we
want the tariffs lifted so that we can
just go back to how things were things
were fine he broke it and you're not
gonna fix it with this little six
billion dollar band-aid that's actually
going to fall off in about six to twelve
months anyway because that's the thing
that people need to understand until the
tariffs are lifted everything we do
whether it's a bailout part of the
bailout also includes the USDA coming in
and buying some of the surplus produce
they're gonna give it to homeless
shelters use it for the military use it
for other things but it's only temporary
I what happens when the next harvest
season comes which we're kind of getting
close to that as well we're gonna have
more surplus is the USDA gonna have to
spend six billion dollars every quarter
just to continuously bail out these
farmers or are we gonna be smart as a
country and get rid of the tariffs that
Trump has put in place because they're
absolutely destroying our economy I
unfortunately believe the answer is
we're gonna keep putting on six billion
dollar band-aids and here's why the
reason this bailout is happening right
now it's not to help the farmers it's to
help the Republican Party that's the
ulterior motive they're not buying
surplus goods they're buying votes
that's what this is about this is a six
billion dollar let's call it an ad buy
for the Republican Party at the expense
of US taxpayers that is our money that's
our money that is being given to them
just to buy their votes for the
Republican Party because as I mentioned
before yeah we have a couple holdouts in
in farm country who say I'll go to the
grave fighting for Trump's trade wars
most of them are not like that most of
them understand that this man doesn't
know what he's doing
the Republicans are complicit with what
he's doing
and this is not a viable policy and it
has to go but if we give them handouts
if we give them you know one hundred two
hundred thousand dollars to keep their
farm going for another six months they
may say okay well I guess I guess this
is okay for now maybe by the time this
money runs out they'll have fix things
and everything will be okay sure I could
vote Republican I guess in the midterms
that is one hundred percent what this is
about this isn't about saving families
this isn't about saving farms this isn't
about buying extra produce and giving it
to homeless people this is about buying
votes to stem the tide of the blue wave
I hope everybody understands that but
part of the blue wave that they're not
going to be able to fix is the fact that
you know there was a retail group
National Retail Federation last week
released a study showing that the
tariffs are going to cost an additional
six billion dollars for US taxpayers
that's in addition to the six billion
we're bailing out it's going to cost us
at an additional six billion dollars in
consumer goods specifically in just the
phirni
furniture and luggage / baggage
industries prices on those goods will
increase for consumers by about six
billion dollars assuming spending levels
stayed the same so we're spending six
billion dollars to give it to the
farmers who are struggling I have
sympathy for them but again they voted
for this guy that they knew wasn't
normal and this is what we could have
all expected but then it's going to cost
us an extra six billion dollars just to
buy a couple different kinds of goods
assuming spending stays the same which
we know it won't once the prices go
sky-high so here's what's going to
happen additionally we're going to see
as prices continue to go up and as we
know wages have fallen and inflation has
already gone up and with the decline in
wages and the rise in inflation our
buying power in the last 12 months has
actually gone down by 3%
now once the
trade war policies start hitting local
stores and everything prices are going
to go up even higher and we're not going
to have the money to buy these things so
sales decline when sales decline they
cut the workforce when the workforce
declines sales decline in other places
because there's fewer people spending
money and so on and so forth as it
ripples through the economy and that is
how economists predict this trade war is
going to help tank things and caused a
major economic collapse Trump doesn't
understand that he wants to bail out the
farmers to buy their votes for the
Republicans for the midterms well who's
going to bail out the furniture industry
who's going to bail out the restaurants
who see their workers or customers not
coming in anymore because they just lost
their job at the furniture company or
furniture factory so they cut ours so
who's gonna bail them out who's gonna
bail out car dealerships when people
can't buy cars anymore because the
prices on those go up we can't just bail
everyone out as what I'm saying we have
to fix the policy that is forcing us to
have to bail people out but to fix it
would have to be for Trump to admit that
he was wrong and that he did this
incorrectly and that'll never happen